the violation of international law and
territorial sovereignty of our friends
in ukraine is totally unacceptable this
is something that we
in georgia i have a number of times
during the past 30 years
witnessed from russia
the aggression that georgia faced
throughout the years
is something that every georgian had to
live through
[Music]
from the first days publicly
um government of georgia head of
georgian government uh president of
georgia speaker of the parliament
have been quite vocal in supporting the
ukrainian cause on the international
forum condemning russian aggression
and
rallying the international community
unfortunately it's probably the lessons
that the world has learned
based on the georgian
tragic experience
that
once you have a bully inside the room
there is no other way of dealing with
this bullet than uh giving me uh an
adequate response so
hopefully and we can see that that the
world uh during the past number of the
days and our friends behind the closed
doors and publicly as well have been
telling us
that the reality that we have been
picturing for years of what the russians
are capable of doing and what they have
done to georgia that unfortunately those
realities came to truth and today we see
that
with the tragic events that are
unfolding in ukraine what we've been
pushing hard
as a message here as well
pushing for additional assumptions
against russia we think the best way of
responding to russian aggression is
building any resilience of the country
by strengthening democracy by being
closer to the west and our paths of
becoming the part of the european union
in nato and we think that
building an open society on open market
principles with a strong economy is the
best response to any
aggression from russia with what we see
right now in the news and with the west
trying to divest from the russian energy
supply
uh the uh caspian energy is the only
alternative source of supply of that
energy
to europe
and all those uh pipelines go through
georgia
russian troops are stationed three four
miles away from those pipelines
so we have to be very vigilant
to make sure that georgia is stable
we've been living in a reality where
uh 12 000 russian troops have been
stationed
close to a capital 40 miles away from
capital for more than a decade
we understand firsthand the threats that
the russian
military and military aggression
presents when it comes to the people of
russia
people of russia to the large extent
have been suffering the
policies of of their government for
years
it is uh
tragic from the
historical perspective of looking at
what is happening to russia right now
and the ideals that existed in russia
after the collapse of the soviet union
beginning of 90s
that the democracy market economy
and the rule of raw will at the end
prevail
all those ideals today have been
shattered
so our hope of people
who believe in a free world and believe
in democracies is that the one day
we will see a light coming out of the of
russia
and hopefully the day will come soon